huge thanks to Harry's for sponsoring
this video if you have hairs that Sprout
from your facial region like myself or
my friend Mario here then you need to
check out Harry's and if you haven't
heard of Harry's before they're an
amazing German company that's been
making razor blades for the past oh 100
years or so so you know they probably
know what they're doing but the coolest
thing about them is how affordable their
blades are see other blade companies
charge more because they can but not
necessarily because they should Harry's
customers are charged the factory direct
price nothing more nothing less but
saving money doesn't matter if the shave
is no good right so take it from me I
shaved using a Harry's razor and hairy
shaving cream and look at this face baby
smooth and with no razor burn whatsoever
if you sprout hair and you own five
dollars then you're in luck because
everything that I used to achieve these
glorious cheeks you can too by clicking
the link in the description below and
receiving a trial set of your very own
for five dollars seriously what are you
waiting for give Harry's a try and show
the world just how smooth those cheeks
can be and now on to the video you
there are a lot of things in the lore of
the Zelda franchise that are confusing
are Link and Zelda related how many
other Realms are there what is the
timeline of course most of these
questions can be answered by way of
speculations and theories both of which
I happen to be a huge fan of you might
have noticed speaking of timelines
though when tears of the Kingdom
released a few months ago we were
greeted with several brand new
confuzzling pieces of lore one of which
is the whole time traveled Loop thing
that happens in an instant Upon
finishing the opening sequence which has
huge implications the more you think
about it so many implications in fact
that it has a lot of Zelda fans
wondering if it's even possible for the
time travel in the game to mesh
seamlessly with the rest of the
franchise with some fans even claiming
that breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom should be heralded as a
non-canon separate continuity altogether
but bear with me because it just so
happens that between myself and my good
buddy Lon Lon historian over on my
Discord server we think we've got this
one all figured out and ready for an
easy explanation that does fit within
the already existing canonical Zelda
timeline well more or less so sit back
relax and prepare to be explained upon
oh and spoiler alert obviously so first
things first let's recap exactly what
happens with the time Loop in the game
when Link and Zelda confront Ganondorf
at the very beginning of the game three
major things happen one Ganondorf wakes
up two the master sword gets properly
rocked by gloom and three Zelda gets
sent back in time after picking up the
zonai secret stone that fell off of
rauru's hand and we can see from the
light dragon's teardrop memories AKA
Zelda's teardrop memories that she was
in fact sent back to the era within
which the kingdom of Hyrule was founded
so you know saying it was a long time
ago would be a massive understatement as
a reminder breath of the wild tells us
of the story of the Calamity that took
place over ten thousand years ago but we
know from in-game lore into creating a
champion timeline that the kingdom of
Hyrule is far older than just 10 000
years the countless additional years
beyond that are referred to only as the
distant past and there's currently no
way of knowing for sure just how many
years in total Hyrule has been a thing
which means there's no way of telling
how many tens or even potentially
hundreds of thousands of years it's been
since Hyrule was founded which according
to the official Zelda Timeline took
place after the events of Skyward Sword
but before the events of the Minish Cap
meanwhile in the future slash present
day time frame link is pulled upwards
into the Sky by raru's hand so that he
can fuse with the hand and awaken
sometime later on the great sky island
where his quest to figure out what the
heck just happened and stopped Ganondorf
from doing bad stuff begins while Zelda
was back in the original Hyrule time for
him though several things happened raru
and Sonia teach Zelda about her time
plus light Powers minaru teaches Zelda
about combining ancient zonai Tech with
futuristic Sheik attack and also how to
transform into a dragon and Ganondorf
threatens the world of Hyrule for the
first time kills Sonja and steals her
secret Stone and transforms into the
demon king and is subsequently sealed
underneath Hyrule castle by rauru Zelda
is also given the master sword from link
far in the future using her own recall
ability that she somehow will gift to
him but already gifted to him in the
future time travel am I right anyway
since the master sword was so bent out
of shape due to the events we saw at the
beginning of the game which would be
ganondorf's Resurrection in the present
day Zelda takes it upon herself to
restore the blade to better status than
it was before by becoming a dragon of
pure light and absorbing the blade
flying high above the land of Hyrule for
countless eras until finally link is
able to draw the blade from her head in
the present day which he then uses to
defeat Ganondorf now right off the bat
we already have some pretty glaring
problems see in the first place the
floating islands didn't rise into the
sky until Zelda went back in time and
raised them alongside her fellow sages
right this means that if it really is a
closed time Loop like the game is
suggesting and as a reminder the game
really is suggesting that it is a closed
time Loop since Ganondorf already knows
Zelda and Link's names upon his
Reawakening meaning this encounter with
raru already happened and raru already
told Ganondorf that link in the master
sword were coming for him which is not
something raru even knew about until
Zelda's appearance in the past so in a
closed time Loop technically speaking
all of the past events should have
already happened and we should be able
to see the effects of all of them in the
present day just like impa's bracelet
that Zelda gives her in the past in
Skyward Sword which is already present
upon meeting her in the future for the
first time in the case of Tears of the
Kingdom the sky islands and the light
dragon should always have been present
in the sky however this is not what
happens as we know from the very
citizens of Hyrule and also the entire
game of breath of the wild that those
islands and even the light dragon
herself really did just pop up out of
nowhere upon the events of the start of
the game which are referred to as the
upheaval and what's even more intriguing
is the sudden appearance of the shrines
of light we can see from the teardrop
memories that the shrines were already
built by the Time Zelda arrived in the
past and if we become super lore Geeks
and study the translated early Hylian
stone tablets that are also floating in
the sky we learned that Sonia and raru
built those shrines in order to seal
away the evil the monsters that they
drove out from the land in order to
found Hyrule which they did before Zelda
arrived in the past so these shrines
were built regardless of anything Zelda
or Ganondorf ever did but you might be
wondering then where did the shrines of
light go by the events of breath of the
wild and why are they randomly back in
tears of the Kingdom one could argue
that the re-emergence of Gloom in
ganondorf's Monsters awakened the
shrines again but not only is that an
awfully convenient explanation it also
completely ignores the presence of
malice which is also a very evil
substance which also created ganondorf's
monsters and also even similarly bathed
the land in the light of the blood moon
plus the light shrines were all created
before Ganondorf transformed into the
demon king and created Gloom so before
Gloom was even a thing but yet they
clearly only show up after the upheaval
there is also the problem of the light
trends that appear on the floating
islands which were raised into the sky
following Sonia's death in raru's
incapacitation although these shrines
clearly function based on different
rules since they don't have
corresponding light Roots like all of
the other shrines on the surface too but
that's another the theory for another
day there is also the entire concept of
Gloom showing up after the events of
breath of the wild that is another hard
pill to swallow so what gives are all of
these problems inexplicable or the
result of poor writing maybe but listen
I wouldn't be making this video to just
sit here and talk about all the stuff
that doesn't make sense that was the
last video no I think there is one
possible explanation that is in my
opinion really the only thing that
allows all of these moving and missing
pieces to fit together so neatly like
they do in tears of the kingdom and it's
also ridiculously simple almost too
simple before warning it is just a
theory and just my own at that so you
are more than welcome to believe what
you'd prefer if it doesn't click with
you but okay here goes nothing I think
it's entirely possible and probable
given everything we see in tears of the
Kingdom that the world of Hyrule that
raru and Sonia are from is another
reality entirely and that the Demon
King's Gloom eventually grew so strong
as he weakened the seal placed on him by
rauru that he eventually somehow
urged his reality with the one we know
of from breath of the wild think about
it Gloom mysteriously started appearing
in the world the sky islands popped into
existence and are falling apart under
the shift of realities the shrines of
light and various zonai architecture
also mysteriously appear all around
Hyrule there are two temples of time now
one of which legitimately used to be
present where the Hylian Temple of Time
Is Now and of course it also explains
the existence of another Ganondorf in
addition to the one we know of that
originated from Ocarina of Time in a
nutshell it explains that feeling that
we all have somewhere in our guts that
the zonai Lord just kind of got slapped
onto Hylian lore now this isn't a
perfect Theory since Zelda mentions that
the cavern's far underneath Hyrule
Castle have been long kept a secret of
the Hylian royal family which heavily
implies that they knew about Ganondorf
being sealed down there for some time
but even that could be excused since
they never confirmed that Ganondorf
himself is the secret that the royal
family was hiding but what do you think
is the closed loop of Tears of the
Kingdom easily explainable and
everyone's just overthinking everything
or is something else necessary to
explain the state of the world and tears
of the Kingdom such as an alternate
reality merging into this one you've got
to admit it would be a neat concept
since we're constantly fighting over the
fact that multiple realities will split
off of one game such as the Fallen
timeline but in this case it would be
the opposite and multiple realities
would merge to create one heck there are
even several people that believe that's
why breath of the wild and subsequently
tears of the Kingdom seem like they have
all of the timelines pouring into them
but that's enough rabbit holding let me
know what you think in the comments
below and thank you so much for watching
this shorter video of mine if you
enjoyed it or my efforts into making it
please consider leaving a like on the
video as it really helps spread it to
other fans just like you and me that
could have these same questions there
will be lots more to come so please make
sure you're subscribed if you haven't
already to be here when that happens
huge thanks as always to my bandico who
make my day every day and that's all
I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I'll see you
next time this is Bandit signing out
peace
thank you
[Music]